就越高 排名就越好 第四个 我们来讲一个关于标题的基本要求 我们至少要知道 这个怎么样的标题才符合平台的规则 我们要根据规则去做符合平台的事情 才能够获得平台更多的流量 首先第一个就是 唯有符合搜索引擎规则的标题 才能够获得更大的流量机会 首先第一个一个标题中
我们不能够使用一些特殊的制服 比如说 货号 斜杠 还有一杠 这些 都可能会被系统识别成无效制服 影响排名
如果你要使用的话 前面加一个空格 第二个就是 这些符号 符代表是不可以用 但是部分行业是可以用的
比如说 逗号啊 这些逗号 这个是在服装中 我已经测试过了 可以用逗号 这个影响不会特别大
但是其他行业的话 你要去测试才知道 不是说所有的行业不能用 只是部分行业不能用
那么第五个我们来讲一些避坑的点 让大家提前知道这个标题的一些规则 以及标题最容易犯的一些错误提前规避
这样的话我们后期所做的标题就没有什么小问题了
首先第一个就是产品名称跟买家搜索词的相关性
它的相关性和关键词的顺序间隔大小是没有关系的
比如说文本的相关性如果买家用文费这个词搜索产品
以下标题的描述方式与从文本上是一样的
只要客户收这个关键词 那么你的这个标题 第一个标题中出现了 只要它出现了这两个关键词
它无论你间隔长远 它是没有任何关系的 它是一样的 能够匹配上的 无论你这个跟这个间隔多远 是没有任何关系的
它的顺序也是没有任何影响的 比如说你把这个词掉到前面 把男的这个词掉到后面
它这个是没有任何影响的 所以说我们不要盲目为了买家搜索 而不断的发新品重复不过 就是不要重重复复的用同样的关键词
你重重复复用同样的关键词 一个是占用你的标题的字符 其实但是它的作用其实跟这些已经是一样的了
所以说就没有必要充充复复的去用 因为它这个标题的跟关键词的顺序 间隔大小 都是没有任何的关系
低坑的第二个就是产品的名称 长度要适大 也就是很多人喜欢就是写非常非常长的关键词标题
这些其实长短跟你的这个本身的关键词的总量是有着极大的一个关系的
但是我们很多人就会忘记名称就是产品的第一匹配要素 比如说我们不要过短也不要过长 数据经过测试的话 我们数据大概显示就是在100个字符左右 一个标题就差不多了 常规的话都在60到85之间 因为买家搜索池是有50个字符限制的 名字太长的话 跟买家搜索的匹配度就不高了
那么它匹配度啊就会密度啊就会下降 买家搜索这都是几个词组组成的 而不是一大段词组 我们在关键词指数里面搜索的时候也看到它并不是一大段的词组 而是一小段的词组
那么不同的行业的产品搜索关键词的数量和关键词指数大小不同 所以说会存在长标题 标题长短不同的差异
比如说你的热门行业可能就是词非常的多 所以说你的标题可能会相对的长一点
但是呢你的有些是冷门行业词非常少 你又非要写很多词 那么你这个标题就会有很多不相关的词 不相关的词就直接会影响到整个标题的精准性以及搜索的精准度
所以一定要结合你的店铺的关键词的总量 以及关键词的准确度去使用 不要一味的追求 标题写长写满 这种是意义不大的 所以说还是从流量的逻辑去思考 标题的组合必须要符合搜索逻辑和精准匹配的相关性 一定要精准的关键词
如果你用了很多都不准的词 那么你在后面去 自动在推广的时候
一定会导致大量的无效的词被点击 甚至大量的那些不精准的流量引进来 那么你这个产品的标签啊 产品的人群啊 都不准确
不准确的时候 那么它的转化率就很低 转化率就很低 你就会看到就是很多都是有点击没有循环的
大概率都是你用了很多精准都不够的词 同时呢 也会容易导致你整个计划的一个高曝光出现 而且你屏蔽了很多词 你有500个屏蔽词的那个数量都不够你屏蔽 所以一定要在我们发产品的时候就把最基本的关系 最基本的标准做好 第三个坑呢 就是产品名称不能罗列和堆砌
我们在写标题的时候不要在一个标题中多个名称 比如说我们这个标题就是一个典型的案例 比如说他这里就描述 女士的卫衣 这里又有T恤 这里又有卫衣 这里又有卫衣跟T恤 所以说你这个标题里面就没有一个核心的核心的关键词的产品词 产品词就是你这个标题到底是在
描述 必须呢 还是位一呢 所以你一个标题 至少要明确一个主核心词是什么 主要的核心词是什么 比如说你就描述的是位一 那么你所有的标题里面最核心的词就是位一就可以了 而不要出现两个或三个品类 这些关键词 这样的话会直接干扰这个系统去判断你到底是在描述什么 旨意不明就会导致它类目也不对
而产品的权重就很低了 那么收手排序肯定会很低的 我们来讲一个
我们一些常见的误区 比如说第一个 标题的核心词越多 排名越容易吗 这是误区其实跟
标题用的核心词多少跟排名是否容易是没有直接的关系的 核心词你用到位了 那么他
排名还有其他的影响因素并不是越多 排名就越靠前
这是错误的一个逻辑 所以说我们不要在关键词里面把那个产品词重复的累加 这种最后面 如果你超过了三个核心的产品词 那么系统就会判定你为对产品标题堆砌 标题堆砌的话 那么你这个产品的权重就很低 就没法获得排名 就像我这里写的一样 从而影响到你的搜索结果影响排序
所以一定要注意这个误区
那么接下来